And looking at the
landscape with new eyes,
this was not a kind of place I'm used to.
Rivers appeared and disappeared
going under and rising
back to the surface.
And these sinkholes, where
the rivers go back in
or where they come out is where
most of the evidence comes from.
We found this in the woods.
Water welling up from
below, and down inside
there'll be artifacts and bones.
Divers have excavated these holes,
finding entire stomach
contents of a Mastodon,
parts of every animal that lived here,
and numerable artifacts from the Ice Age.
We cannon-balled
into this particular one,
and I remember the
current tugging at my feet
and how dark it was when I looked down.
Shadows falling into shadows.
One researcher described
diving in one of these holes
with another excavator and
pulling a long ivory shaft
out of a crack --part of a throwing weapon--
and he was so excited
that he was shouting over his regulator.
And another diver told
me about drifting down
to the bottom with a weight belt
and it's being completely
black down there,
flicking on a thousand watt light,
and the megafauna bones
were all around him,
glowing like gold.
I think of these as emergence places,
spots on the land where the
Ice Age pokes up through.
This is the Gault site in central Texas,
and it has human artifacts
going back 25,000 years.
I walked down into this pit
and I was going layer by layer,
going down through time,
and the lower I got,
the more of the ground of
the trenches became wet.
And there were generators going
and hoses pumping water back out
because this was cut down
below the water table,
down to where people left
artifacts 25,000 years ago.
If the pump stopped running,
this would just fill up
like a swimming pool.
And of course, I'm thinking
about the old stories down here
about the old Diné man who told me
that the people came from the ground.
So many of those original stories
are about this watery underworld.
And I thought, is this the
place they're talking about?
Is this one of the emergence sites?
We got into the bags of artifacts
and found the oldest one there,
the last artifact that had been picked up.
This is a core left
behind from manufacturer.
But you hold it and you think,
at the time I was there,
they were only down
to the 15,000-year layer,
and I was thinking,
this was touched by
somebody 15,000 years ago.
This thing felt like a time machine.
People arrived in this continent
and then went everywhere.
And this rock was still
wet, as if from birth.
(deep gong)